hello freak [ __ ] imagine if your
daughter was taking dancing lessons from
Patrick Swayze he's got that [ __ ]
silky mullet and he's dancing and moving
across the floor and yeah no guy does
that unless he wants to [ __ ] either guys
he's [ __ ] your daughter that's why I
dance is so good his hips around you
want to let you know this is how I [ __ ]
you dude imagine spinning around off the
style polyester pants
do you remember Saturday Night Fever you
remember when it came out where
everybody wanted to go dancing yeah I
was a little kid but I remember dressing
like him what year did Saturday Night
Fever 77 was it yeah so it was 10 years
me jeez
and I remember people just would go
dancing all the time it's true and
they're wearing like all open shirts my
aunts were living with us at the time oh
yeah moved from New Jersey or Florida
where the [ __ ] they were at the time I
think they they move with us around that
same time when I was 10 I feel they they
went dancing
were they fun ants yeah they were nice
look at this here it is yeah oh Jesus
oh yeah look at this shirt open shirt
look at the hair because I never had
hair like that what a great album
it's amazing the Bee Gees the Bee Gees
were incredible credible wish we could
play some of it on the podcast
whoo if you can sing like that and if
you had a cigarettes on cigarette smoke
in there playing records and it was all
about going out and everybody would go
dancing and occasionally knife fights
accidentally yeah she was cute but she
wasn't as hot as the other girl when she
dropped the condoms in it I was like
what were those yeah he's happening he's
looking at a I can't believe how good
she is you want to give me lessons next
thing you know they're banging she's not
from his side of the tracks be with them
and you know he's kind of flawed and but
he's got this special something and he
could really get dance you can really
dance Tony you can really you think so
for real yeah you could really dance
time they just wanted to dance no yeah
no one does that anymore I know he just
hadn't loved songs there were so many
love songs in the seventies
just life in general was different yeah
came out of the Vietnam War and stuff he
just wanted to just chill out and love a
little bit Oh as we're getting
overwhelmed with data and information
this becomes more and more ridiculous
you look at like I'm making a movie
exactly like this today and you could
make one of those likes step on up dance
movies I am but those movies are stupid
well I am but I don't know what that is
that's the one that almost won the award
yeah it was a it was a big hit this year
and it was a musical and there was a lot
of dancing mmm well did you see it I did
how dare you theater queens we weren't
in the theater we were watching it at
home I got the screener and my kids
wanted to see it I didn't really enjoy
it will you listen it's an anomaly I was
inviting a raccoon while they were
dancing and I was biting a raccoon in
the face oh that's rough night
but it was us but it was kind of this it
was kind of dancing and lalala what I'm
saying is this is a dumb movie and if
you want to make this dumb movie today
it wouldn't be so interesting it would
be silly you'd be like this is so silly
yeah but now the people we know more
about how people are uh-huh you know
it's just any was different and we've
seen a lot of stuff so things can't be
so shitty yeah I was watching everything
I saw someone had a thing for a speed
buggy remember that cartoon speed buggy
no I don't it was like it it was like a
cartoon when we read buggy speed god you
remember yeah and I had the guy with the
goggles and they would do this little
theme song and who would go its speed
buggy
do this right and they'd go speed buggy
and then speed buggy goes that's me
wait a minute does that have anything to
do with scooby-doo or they just thieves
I think probably the same those people
exactly like the scooby-doo P yeah yeah
that's that scooby-doo instead of the
car is scooby-doo yeah that's shaggy
yeah yeah and those that's the other two
people they're really saying
right rockin the cheerleader we're in
the same clothes yeah look that's Jimmy
fight crimes and they find out who the
bad guys are
oh the gorillas almost gets it like see
that guy in the back that's the jock and
the girl on the front yep
that's like Veronica it was so simple
like you wouldn't make this now good
luck Gilligan's Island speed buggy
that's me did you make Gilligan's Island
without people banging you tell me the
only one that's banging is Thurston
Howell and his wife yeah they're the
only ones who are banging if the old
ones are married lovey
nobody else is even kissing nobody okay
this sailor the [ __ ] the skipper and
Gilligan
don't they have bunk beds they have a
bunk hammocks yeah is that the most
obvious gay couple ever get over your
little buddy look at this we're gonna
have to [ __ ] smoking hot girls and
then there's the two camps like which
camp are you you camp ginger you can't
Mary Ann right I like a regular girl
look I could take fishing like the girl
next door
yeah she looks sexy for one girl it
looks good on a red carpet I'm more at
ginger type and the professor was like
the intelligent one and he wasn't that
smart
Dabangg either nobody get to bang nobody
bang the professor wasn't intelligent
not really it was like seventies science
and bones what's he know back then right
now he's like look I found a bird you
can tell by its wings he's not concerned
that stupid Birds let's hold it like but
birds are prey like they can constantly
does that burn have any instincts if you
eat it it's probably poisoned this was a
hit yeah this one's got a hit it's
runaway hit he's rehabbing this bird I
think if I remember correctly Gilligan's
Island was on for far less time than we
think oh really
yeah I believe that I thought I think it
did a few seasons how many seasons if
you yes I loved it when I was a child
were we seeing it in reruns yeah yeah
for sure
67-64 67 see it's only a three year
years how many episodes 30 episodes
that's crazy
I guess it's 4 years if they did a full
season for each year that is pretty
short that's crazy how many episodes was
it say should I find out might have been
30 per season really it's a lot yeah a
lot of storylines usual usually it's 22
because you would get 13 that would be
your big order and then you would get
the back 9 this was olden times well
this is real olden times where they
didn't get paid so Gilligan skipper and
everybody they got [ __ ] played these
things they're playing them somewhere
now so whoever owns them they own it
forever and you don't get our you don't
get residuals Wow poor Gilligan they
paved the way though a lot of shitty
ships but there's still make like goofy
shows you know what's so interesting
like the all the kid shows that the kids
get raised on like these Disney shows
and stuff they're as goofy as all this
stuff in the 70s
[Applause]
[Music]